oh the chicago bears started off five
and one and have lost six in a row now
five and seven and the ship is sinking
quickly it's time for a little pft pm
mpm qb second guessing some of the
decisions made by coaches on the sunday
that was and
the play calling of the chicago bears
offense
under two minutes up three inside their
own ten
third and four
they were actually on their own 17. the
fumble happened inside the 10 though
mitchell trubisky goes back he has no
awareness gets hit ball comes out
detroit recovers detroit scores detroit
wins they were down 10 they erased that
deficit just like chicago erased a
double-digit deficit against detroit
earlier this year at ford field here's
matt nagy yesterday when he was asked
about the decision to throw the ball
while trying to
get out of there with a victory
you know third and four and we have to
you know we're backed up
or we don't really have the field
position so
um we have to get a first down we have
to make them user timeouts and uh you
know we ran a play that's good versus
all coverages you know it's if they show
man grade it has answers versus zero
and then if they play zone we got
answers there as well so we felt good
with that um and it's just a play at
least what i saw from the jumbotron
afterwards is kid made a good play
around the edge and was able to swipe
his arm out and make a play
i'd have to go back and see you know as
far as the pushing up in the pocket and
and and you know other guys within the
route where that was but we we had to
stay aggressive there and get first
downs to make them use their timeouts
and try to end the end with the football
and win the game is there anything you
say on the headset before that play goes
off
no no i think uh the biggest thing is
it's just
that's a
that play for us is a uh you know it's
day one training camp and it's something
that that all those guys know inside out
yeah look it's just a bad situation in
chicago regardless of who the
quarterback is nick foles and mitch
trubisky it is crumbling two years ago
matt nagy was the coach of the year a
lot of coach of the years in recent
years end up not being the coaches for
much longer after that it just shows you
how quickly things can fall apart
and
they've fallen apart for the bears i
don't know how they get out of this
vortex of suck at this point but that's
where they are
and you just wonder if and when big
changes are going to be made there and
if it's going to be the gm if it's going
to be the head coach if it's going to be
the team president who it's going to be
but you know bears fans have been
through a lot over the years they
haven't had a true franchise quarterback
since sid luckman and this just isn't
sustainable in chicago shireen
yeah it's horrible mike i'm curious who
do you blame more for for that play
do you blame the play caller or do you
blame mitchell trubisky more i mean
they're both at fault we agree on that
but but who do you blame more for that
play
well i think the play caller because as
the play caller you have to know the
limitations of your players number one
you don't have the offensive line to buy
the guy the time that he needs number
two you don't have the quarterback who
has the awareness to get rid of the
football quickly before he gets hit and
the ball comes out so you've got to have
a different strategy as the play caller
you have to have the awareness of what
your team can and can't do
especially since it's been so long since
a win you've got to take the easiest
path to killing the clock and getting
out of there and even if it means
punting that's better than getting cute
you don't have patrick mahomes you don't
have the kansas city chiefs offense
where you could maybe drop back and
deliver the dagger with a first down
throw and then take a knee take a knee
and go home you've got to play within
the limitations of what you have so i
put it on the play caller
yeah you know and he does have four
fumbles in
the last five games and he cringed at
when he was asked the question or do you
have a fumble problem and he said he
doesn't but it's obvious he does it obvi
it's obvious he holds on to the ball too
long sometimes and
and that to me is a case where you can't
trust your quarterback and even if you
run the ball and force detroit to call
its last time out and punt i think
you're better off than than doing what
they chose to do obviously and it's easy
to sit here and second guess when it
doesn't work but i don't know even if
that's a day one training camp play and
you've run it a million times i'm still
not trusting mitchell trubisky to run
that play and you mentioned he doesn't
have patrick mahomes but we all know
they could have had patrick mahomes
matt nagy did have patrick mahomes for a
year
he did in kansas city before he got the
job you can't blame
the patrick mahomes failure to be a bear
on matt naggy but you can't blame it on
ryan pace that's why i hope they don't
and i'm not advocating at this point i
don't know what the hell they're going
to do in chicago i think if they're
going to make big changes at some point
they have to
aim up at team president ted phillips
who's been there for 21 years making
these hiring and firing decisions but
you know i i think the worst thing they
could do is fire ryan pace and keep matt
nagy and then bring in a gm that maybe
doesn't want matt nagy and then you've
got this function until you fire matt
neggy that's not good for anybody so
good luck to the bears figuring out
what's right for them the broncos trying
to figure out what's right for them on
sunday night you know they hey
the thing about the chiefs because they
face the absolute best that every
opponent has to offer for every team
that plays them it's the super bowl it's
the moment it's the opportunity to have
a measuring stick type of a game the
chiefs have to be up every week and we
see it they're not up every week so you
can catch them napping from time to time
the broncos had some chances they made
some bad decisions the first one came
late in the first half 57-yard field
goal by brandon mcmanus a reliable
kicker in denver the altitude different
in kansas city and the thing about a 57
yarder it's one thing to try it with two
ticks on the clock it's another thing to
try a 57-yarder with 33 seconds left in
the half and you're giving the ball pat
back to patrick mahomes so mcmanus
misses the chiefs get the ball on their
47 and the next thing you know
a 10-3 margin becomes 10
6. no 10-9 it was 10-6 it becomes 10-9
it's got a different feel going into
half-time all because they got a little
greedy maybe a little stupid in
going for the field goal with that much
time left on the clock shireen
i almost would have preferred that they
had gone for it there i'm not gonna lie
i didn't have a huge problem with the
field goal just because you trust
brandon mcmanus so much but you're right
you don't have the altitude that you
have in denver i know it was fourth and
eight but if you don't get it at least
you're on the 39 and no it's not that
much of a difference but if you do get
it then it set you up for a field goal
at least and maybe a touchdown and
you're gonna run out the clock and
you're not going to give kansas city the
ball back hopefully you can run off that
last 33 seconds so i almost would have
preferred that they had gone for it
there and mike i think there is a
difference when you're a non-playoff
team and you're not really in the
playoff race even though mathematically
maybe you're still in it but i do think
there's a difference when you're that
team and trying to build toward 2021 and
when you're a team trying to play for
the postseason and this to me was a team
that needed to take some chances and go
for it and they didn't do that they they
made to me two really bad coaching
decisions
yeah and the decision that ended up
being the the worst one
and vic fangio seemed to acknowledge
after the game that
maybe he shouldn't have done it today he
doubled down on the decision he made
down by three points 1916 six minutes
and 13 seconds remaining in the game
facing fourth and three on their own 49
they opted not to go for it they opted
to punt
and when you see look throw aside
analytics
and and this isn't meant to disrespect
the analytics crowd for me there's one
factor
that rises above all others when it
comes to analytics
are you keeping patrick mahomes on the
sideline yes or no
okay if you go for it and you get it
yes he's on the sidelines if you punt it
he's on the field and we've all seen
that patrick mahomes is a different guy
when the game's on the line when it's
time to go do it you know we all have
that moment there are different times in
our lives whether it's at work or if
there's a personal issue
we accept now's the time to go take care
of business and i think the chiefs are
that team more than any other in the nfl
that i can remember in years where
they'll just kind of coast and just kind
of coast and it's like okay it's time to
take care of business you gotta you
gotta understand that as a football
coach so
uh you you well we gotta make a stop
well yeah you gotta make a stop but it's
the chiefs it'd be different if it was
the chargers or if it was the jets or if
it was some other team and i know these
analytics formulas sharing are getting
more complex and they take those things
into account but
i have no faith in any analytics formula
that dictates that you should give the
ball back to patrick mahomes in a spot
where he's likely to along with his
teammates know it's time to go to work
yeah mike two things on this one i'm
wondering how much vic fangio being a
defensive minded coach played into this
i would think that a more offensive
minded coach would have wanted the ball
in the hands of his offense rather than
putting it on his defense to stop
patrick mahomes and so i do wonder if if
vic fangio being a defensive mind who
coached that played into his thinking
and the second thing is i think it would
have done a lot for drew locke even if
they don't make it if you go to drew
lock whether you call timeout or
whatever but you say look we're gonna
trust you to pick up this this first
down we're gonna put the ball in your
hands we're putting it on you to win
this game and you know what if they had
made that and gone on to have won this
game that could have really been a
turning point for drew lock and this
team but they didn't and they didn't
give him that chance and now you have to
wonder to through lock second guess
himself saying well they don't trust me
enough in that situation to put the ball
in my hands so you had an opportunity
there to do something for drew lock and
i think you failed drew luck by not
giving him a chance again you're a four
win team go for it do what you have to
do to try to win the game and give your
team some momentum going into 2021.
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports